ce réseau néo nazis n'est
malheureusement pas isolé d'une manière
générale la liberté pratiquement totale
qui règne sur internet qui se joue des
frontières permettent de créer des
réseaux qui peuvent se révéler donc très
très dangereux au site néo nazi
antisémite on peut ajouter les réseaux
de pédophilie de prostitution encore de
trafic de drogue wade les fourneaux
c'est une règle 1 j'ai l'oeil du tracker
rivés sur internet un jeu de patience
mais d'embûches pour marc noël avant de
remonter jusqu'à la source des
extrémistes et leur nid d'aigle comme ce
site néo nazis du groupe chs incite
aujourd'hui interdit en france qui
envoie virtuellement les noms à rien les
sous-hommes et les juifs à auschwitz un
site parmi multitude internet est une
toile d'araignée donc avec la toile
d'araignée ou la constituent et au fur
et à mesure que vous avancez vous
naviguez sur internet son site devienne
deux cents 200 deviennent 6 ans et ainsi
de suite
c'est un foisonnement à tiroirs qui se
reconstitue tous les jours et s'ils
disparaissent les sites se reconstitue
des sites de plus en plus violents sans
limite au caire et d'un simple clic on
trouve le pire sur internet
la panoplie du parfait poseurs de bombes
par exemple certains sites détails plus
de 400 manière de tuer de la lettre
piégée à la bombe nucléaire
internet c'est aussi une vitrine pour le
gia qui affiche qu'il arrive aux prêtres
aux ennemis de leur cause
plus interactif les adorateurs de satan
conversion le meilleur moyen de tuer
leurs voisins mais dans la constellation
des sites extrémistes
le gros de la troupe c'est l'extrême
droite les révisionnistes de tous poils
pour une nation blanchet aryenne une
présence que ne peuvent ignorer les
fournisseurs d'accès ceux qui vendent le
droit d'entrée à internet en tant que
fournisseur d'accès internet
c'est beaucoup plus difficile à
contrôler ou de par l'univers est pas
extensible d'une part et infini
d'internet
cela contraindrait
en fait c'est à ce moment qu'elles sont
à peine faisabilité technique ou est ce
que vous mettez des millions de
personnes à contrôler chaque site
je vais expliquer comment vous faites
certains juristes eux ont une réponse
il suffirait que les pouvoirs publics
considèrent ces fournisseurs d'accès
comme les complices des extrémistes car
pour l'instant malgré les lois
françaises les professionnels de
l'internet peuvent vendre un abonnement
à n'importe qui même mois une entreprise
commerciale qui héberge un site
contractuellement qui choisit de
divulguer un site donné sur le réseau
internet doit être qualifié d'éditeur le
problème c'est que la loi ne le dit pas
et même si la france voter une telle loi
le problème ne serait pas réglé pour
autant un site des ménages vite avant
leur arrestation
les néonazis du chs avaient déjà trouvé
la parade
aujourd'hui encore leurs amis et met en
toute tranquillité depuis le canada